Everybody.
I was expecting to be like a tiny room with like 20 people.
Oh Wow.
This is a tiny room for us,
Lord.
Wow.
This is amazing.
All right.
Hi everyone.
Welcome to toxic Google today.
It is my pleasure to welcome Ryan Reynolds for Deadpool.
Right.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Very nice to be here.
Thanks for joining us.
Yeah,
I feel like I'm rubbing shoulders with real power.
We were at Google of it.
Yes.
Um,
Brian,
how excited are you for people to see this movie?
Uh,
I'm,
I could not be more excited.
Actually,
I'm 11 years excited.
I,
uh,
when I talk about it,
I always just grateful I'm wearing an adult diaper.
The,
uh,
this movie has been the biggest pain in the ass to get made.
And somehow some way a,
the movie gods looked down on us in and made that happen through a number of
illegal transactions,
not the least of which being a ar test footage leaking onto the Internet,
uh,
accidentally about,
two years ago.
And that's what gave us the green light.
So I'm thrilled to talk about Deadpool movie cause I didn't,
I never thought Deadpool would actually be,
it would exist.
It's,
it's been an 11 year thing and it's the worst relationship I've ever been in.
But we're happily married now and,
uh,
and,
and we're,
we're expecting congratulations.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Uh,
would it be fair to say the Internet helped make this movie happen do yet?
No,
it would be,
it would be absolute fact to say that the Internet,
the Internet is why I'm sitting here talking to you.
I'm quite literally,
it was,
uh,
the fans,
overwhelmed 20th century Fox studios with a hate mail.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm sure other illegal substances filled in sorts of all sorts of containers.
They were,
they were vicious and they,
um,
they owe so overwhelmed Fox with feedback and positive feedback about a Deadpool
movie that,
uh,
that,
yeah,
here we are relatively short order.
They were,
they were basically said,
go make your movie and leave us alone because we,
we were sending emails,
we sent emails to the heads of the studio that you would never send to the head
of a major film studio.
They were just like,
just borderline illegal.
Uh,
so,
um,
yeah,
the,
I think they were just happy to say,
here's the green light.
Now please leave us alone.
And they left us alone,
so we got to make the movie that we'd always dreamt drempt off.
So yeah.
How relieved were you when they said,
yeah,
I'd make an r rated movie.
You guys embraced that?
We,
uh,
we hugged it like a cuddly Koala,
is not the word.
Yeah.
We a,
yes,
we dry humped a cuddly Koala into an r rating,
which just weirdly legal,
uh,
we had,
we had a blast.
No,
they,
the only way to make Deadpool is to make it,
uh,
without any kind of a reservation.
And,
uh,
having a PG 13 just wouldn't really allow us to have the creative freedom we
needed to,
to sort of really bring to life in the most authentic way.
This,
this marvel character and you know,
and he lives within x man universe.
So technically he's kind of orbiting the same areas is,
you know,
Wolverine and all these other guys.
So they're all sort of touched upon in the movie.
And,
uh,
we see a couple of other x men.
And I just think personally on a personal level,
it's just funny to me to see,
ah,
like this,
you know,
me yelling at another x band that he's a wheezing bag of Dick tips and the fact
that like,
they let me get away with that with was a refreshing,
I'll say.
Yeah.
Uh,
how would you convince someone's grandmother to go see this movie?
Would,
would that be the exact phrasing you'd use?
Wheezing bag addictives is a start for sure.
Um,
uh,
no,
I,
I think what's funny is,
is that a lot of,
um,
a lot of,
I've seen some older women at some of the screenings and they loved it.
I mean,
but then again,
Bendix sort of go in knowing what they're,
what they're getting.
Um,
but in terms of,
uh,
I think,
you know,
I think you just have to lift grandma up and physically take her to the theater
and yeah,
just tell her we're going to go see it on golden pond.
Uh,
part two are driving miss daisy or something like that.
And Yeah.
Hope it doesn't kill her.
Yeah.
Um,
what's,
what's been the most surreal experience,
either filming the movie or afterwards?
Oh,
the most surreal experience by far was,
was,
um,
was the day I,
uh,
it was the day I walked into film illusions,
there's a gentleman named Russ Schenkel who's the guy in Hollywood that makes
all the really cool,
you know,
Superhero costumes.
You know,
he's the,
he's,
he's the go into a shop and you see that,
oh,
there's Batman and Oh,
there's,
you know,
the Spiderman and there's,
but he,
uh,
he had spent months and months trying to get the Deadpool suit right.
We are sort of edict at the beginning was this has to look,
this has to be the most face faithful comic book to Screen Costume Adaptation.
That's been,
and it's ever been attempted.
And he met that challenge,
uh,
tenfold when I saw that was the most surreal moment where I saw the suit for the
first time.
And,
and I,
and I'm not exaggerating or trying to be funny,
I wept.
I cried because it was this 11 year journey and I thought,
wow,
we're,
we're off to the races here.
I mean,
we really are on to something.
If we're starting the movie off on this foot,
on this footing,
this is going to be really special.
So that was,
that was pretty surreal.
And well,
speaking of the suit,
uh,
it's,
it's interesting to have a superhero who we kind of don't always actually want
to see his face.
No,
it's aesthetic reasons.
Um,
so how,
how did you sort of approach that performance?
I,
it looked like,
so like the eyes are animate a little bit,
which was awesome,
but you also have to combine that with your body language and then raw
physicality of,
yeah,
there's,
well,
we sorta,
uh,
in the screenwriting process,
we started developing the script six years ago,
myself,
Rhett Reese and Paul were and can read recent pulmonic road,
Zombie land.
And they're,
they're just like really fun,
smart,
engaging,
really funny writers.
And,
and uh,
we all sat around,
we sort of felt like you needed it for an origin story on Deadpool.
You need a third,
a third,
a third.
So a third looks like me.
And then a third looks like the scarred version of Wade who we affectionately
say looks like Shrek took a shit on his shoulders.
And then you have the,
the masked version of,
of,
of Deadpool.
And that is sort of the,
the,
the true embodiment of the character and the spirit.
So,
um,
it was always a challenge.
I mean,
the mask pushing emotions through the mask is interesting.
Like I,
two days before shooting,
I produced the movie.
So I was,
I,
I got luxuries that I would never have as an actor.
I actually got to assemble a small camera crew and say,
I need to just go into a room.
I need you to fill me acting like a moron for about two days.
So I could just see how the suit behaves and how the suit moves and how it,
how much expression I could have through the suit.
So,
um,
I learned a ton.
I've got to do a lot of r and d with the suit and,
um,
you know,
it was,
we were shocked.
You could actually really kind of come through that.
You know,
there was a little bit of facial animation in the eyes,
which really helped us,
but by and large,
you know,
we love the scenes where you were not even animating the face.
It's just a,
just sort of work.
So yeah,
it was,
it was great to see this sort of like the physical LSA comedy parts,
and then,
yeah,
you have to be really big.
You know,
you have to be like a little,
you have to sort of take a tip from clown school a little bit when you're in
that thing.
So all my,
all my reactions of sort of huge.
So when,
when were you first introduced to the character of Deadpool?
I was on a set,
I was on the,
the movie Blade Trinity,
which,
um,
uh,
I hope,
I hope most of you if not seeing,
um,
but,
uh,
no,
I,
there's some,
there's some fun parts that movie,
but,
but it's,
it's uh,
it was a movie where I got to have a lot of fun.
Uh,
I got to do the movie with my friends.
It was certainly the,
the movie was fraught with a lot of,
a number of different frustrations that sometimes big movies can have.
But uh,
but I played a character in that movie that I guess resembles Wade Wilson and
Deadpool and,
uh,
I,
I not rival executive at another studio is that I saw a little piece of blade
and you know,
you're Wade Wilson,
you're Deadpool.
And I didn't know at the time,
this is in 2004.
I didn't know who Deadpool was.
And he said,
trust me,
they ever make a movie about Deadpool.
You're the only guy that can play Deadpool.
So he sent me over all these comics and I,
I'm not a big comic book guy,
but I've really gravitated toward Deadpool.
I fell in love with Deadpool.
Um,
the first,
uh,
issue,
I opened up,
I not making this up.
I was on the panel,
like in,
in the comic it said,
Deadpool was saying,
I,
somebody asked him what he looks like.
He says,
I look like a cross between Ryan Reynolds and a Sharpei.
And I was like,
Jesus,
this is fucking destiny.
I,
what the hell?
Who's fucking with me?
It's like,
you know,
Kirk Cameron gonna jump out of the corner with his little candid camera and I'm
going to offend him with my squares.
Um,
so I just kept,
I kept reading them all and I was just so in,
fell so in love with this character.
He was like Metta.
He breaks the fourth wall,
addresses the audience.
He knows he's in a comic book.
I mean,
you know,
in the,
in the film,
Deadpool,
Deadpool makes fun of Ryan Reynolds and I love that.
I love that he gets to do that.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a kind of a groundbreaking Shondra bending property and the fact that a
studio let us make it,
uh,
not just let us make it bit,
let us make it.
It also has a rated r movie was just,
I mean crazy.
I couldn't believe it.
So it's uh,
I think,
I think Deadpool,
the comic characters definitely very self aware and yeah,
you guys very much embrace that and pop culture.
Yeah,
there's a lot attic history in culture references in it and there's like,
the movie has over a hundred Easter eggs too.
I mean,
it's just little things like that.
Some things that you may not see that I,
I don't know if we'll,
if we ever get the opportunity to shoot another Deadpool movie or another 10 if
I have my way,
um,
I,
I'll use in those.
So I don't want to really give them away.
But there's,
there's so many great little Easter eggs.
It was so much fun to plan all these things in the movie of what you can tell
us.
What was one of your favorite things to film for the movie?
Um,
oh God.
Of what are the I probably my favorite scene,
there's a scene where Deadpool,
uh,
attacks another x men.
And I just liked it that in this moment we're really embodying the moral
flexibility of the character.
I mean,
that's one of the things that I personally love about Deadpool so much is that
he,
he ostensibly looks like a superhero,
but he's morally flexible in every way.
Like,
and that's,
that to me is just you do,
you get a lot of superheroes that are tough and that talk like this and the Hay.
But Deadpool's like he genuinely is a guy that'll just sort of help out whoever
has the,
the,
the fattest wad of cash.
And I love that about him.
And so there's a scene where he just,
he just,
he is,
ego gets bruised and he just attacks this x men named the Colossus and at the
scene,
uh,
he ends up breaking every bone in his body attacking colossus.
And I just love that scene because he just never shuts up the whole time.
He just keeps us running,
editorial,
going of everything that's happening.
And it's,
that's an,
there's a lot of fun.
So every bone,
it was graphically to,
um,
uh,
what's,
what's one of the things that you did in the preparation process that you
weren't sort of expecting to have it a large effect on playing the park?
The prep for me was easy.
I was,
it was basically being eased out of my mother's womb and then being fed enough
to grow into adulthood and then beginning filming.
I mean,
I,
to me it was just,
it was a matter of that marriage between myself and Paul Wernick and just
finding these two writers that,
that's so understood everything that we were trying to do.
And um,
and those guys had been such a privilege to,
not only to know,
but to work with.
Also,
the thing I love about Denver was the marketing campaign is an extension of the
film,
which is not normal.
You know,
most times we didn't have a character that breaks the fourth wall and addresses
the audience directly.
The,
the possibilities for a film or obviously limitless,
but so is the marketing.
So for me,
the marketing has been a lot of fun.
We've been shooting,
I think we shot over 40 viral videos.
Um,
maybe only 12 or 15 we've released that.
We have so many,
I mean it's just a bare an embarrassment of riches,
but half the time it was just me and my iPhone just,
you know,
shooting myself with the trailer or wherever and you know,
while we were shooting.
So,
um,
that part's been amazing.
I think.
Yeah,
I think you guys have done a great job of building the excitement amongst the
fans.
Yeah,
well not,
I mean people knew about Deadpool a year ago and I feel like they've done a
great job of really introducing him to the uninitiated as well.
So what's been one of the greatest sort of fan experiences?
Cause I think there's a very rapid call upon me.
God,
it was crazy.
I was,
cause last time it was at comicon was,
was I was there for green lantern and uh,
and that was tough.
Like,
you know,
you're so,
uh,
you know,
you sorta feel like,
I'm so close to Deadpool and I'm so intimate with it that like I haven't,
zero objectivity.
I mean,
absolutely zero.
So walking into comicon,
everybody's laughing and smiling and Rhett Reese,
Paul Wernick and Tim Miller,
the director and everything.
I was just laughing at backslapping and I just have sheet white and terrified
cause I have no idea how it was.
I'm too close to it.
So then when the,
when the are our presentation played,
we showed them about three or four minutes of the movie,
um,
and it finished and they were all on their feet.
And then there they started chanting one more time,
one more time and that are on the side stage.
I looked over there and I could see the studio head who had waited 10 years
degree,
like the movie just looking at me like with this smile on her face.
Like,
well there you fucking go.
You know.
Um,
and,
and Hugh Jackman was actually standing next to her cause wolverine,
uh,
that they were doing wolverine presentation next and he,
he actually told them,
play it one more time or they're going to fucking riot.
So they played it one more time or our presentation and that,
that to me was like,
I was so surreal.
It was such a magical moment.
I mean,
just for everybody,
because we didn't make the movie on,
I mean,
I always joke like we,
our budget for Deadpool was what,
you know,
most superhero movies spend on just cocaine.
So like for us it was,
you know,
we didn't have,
$200 million to sort of make all our dreams come true.
We every single cent counted.
And Tim Miller,
our director is like,
he's a visual effects guru.
He owns a visual effects company.
So he made,
he made every dollar turn,
magically turned into 10.
I don't know how he did that.
And um,
I'm so grateful to him for like making everything,
us being able to realize our vision for the movie and really kind of put
everything that was on the page,
on the screen at a cost that you can't tell we compromised.
I mean,
it still feels like you're watching him,
you know,
one of these movies with these massive budgets and,
and uh,
yeah,
but just way less recreational drugs.
So cocaine fall under craft services you think?
I don't know.
You know,
it's funny,
but like,
you know,
obviously that never happens anymore,
but,
well,
maybe it does.
Uh,
but uh,
the,
the it back in the 80s,
you could always look at,
I,
you'd always,
they always talk about like the,
the,
the line,
the line costs on a movie and stuff,
and there'd always be this like miscellaneous line that was like $80,000 and
they'd just be like,
oh no,
that was just individually wrapped Norwegian toffee and,
and you're like,
right,
right.
Whatever you call it.
Uh,
we're going to take audience questions in a moment if anyone wants to line up.
Thank God.
No,
I'm kidding.
You've been doing great.
Even doing so great.
You've been doing an amazing thank you.
Thank you very much.
Very much.
My two weeks notice and a big hand for,
and please come on.
She's amazing.
You've been doing?
Um,
I think a lot of people on the Internet,
we're curious where there any onset shenanigans and if so,
can you tell us about anyway,
I'm not a ta.
Like surprisingly for a movie like this,
there weren't a ton of onset shenanigans is a lot of it was just alternate
jokes.
I mean,
we just had so much fun with massive,
I,
it was just a matter of time that sort of pulled us away from each scene.
But like we would do 15 all jokes for everyone you see in the movie.
So the home entertainment package or whatever the hell they,
I'm like so old.
I'm like,
the laser disc package for this film is going to be exceptional.
Uh,
know that the digital package that comes after it,
they're going to have everything.
I mean,
all the,
the gag reel is just stupid stupid power cut.
Yeah.
You could do like a nine or,
I mean,
there's so many little extras that,
that,
that stuff's gonna be fun,
I think.
And do you have a,
a personally,
do you have a favorite furniture line?
Any favorite?
Oh
or Varsha is a dead Paul's personal favorite though.
They'd be yours.
That things just absolute bullshit.
And I think we all know it
for anyone who hasn't seen the movie here or there just going,
what the fuck is he talking about?
Deadpool in the movie forces his blind elderly roommate to assemble Ikea
furniture all day because he's a wonderful guy to stand up citizen.
Um,
so my question is,
what's a fictional character that you wish to play but haven't?
Oh,
that's a good question.
Not Bella from twilight
fictional character that,
uh,
there's a,
oh,
so boring answer.
There's a great,
uh,
prison baseball player named Lynn Blackie Schwamm from I think the 20s and
thirties.
And he was known as the greatest prison baseball player ever.
He was a pitcher,
but he was totally debilitated by alcoholism.
And I,
I've always been sort of totally fascinated by his story and,
uh,
so I would love to,
I would love to play Blackie Schwamm in a,
in a,
in a movie that nobody will ever make.
Yeah.
Well they said that about Deadpool and then they made that.
So you never know.
Right,
right,
right.
In your letters,
I know how passionate you all are about Blackie Schwamm so it begins now pickins
out.
Um,
actually what,
what sort of other,
what have your other acting experiences,
you bring your sitters a moment that I was sort of reliving your,
uh,
your performance and like buried.
Oh,
he's just really good at like freaking out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Were there,
were there any moments you're like,
oh no,
I am good at freaking out.
It's false faces.
I'm pretty,
like I all,
I'm the first guy to say like a movie I did,
or if I to said it sucked,
but like I,
uh,
yeah,
that's the one gift I've always had is freaking out in small spaces.
It's because probably because I'm the youngest of four boys,
so I was often crammed into small spaces,
both for survival and for torture.
So,
um,
but yeah,
and the movie eye in dead poet's certainly like I'm choking to death and I'm
being tortured and,
and uh,
I am fine with it,
but the problem is it blows all the blood vessels in my face.
So,
uh,
I have to,
they have to end up like putting a lot of a lot of makeup on the cover up my a
horribly blood vessel blown face,
your horrible face on and makeup [inaudible] makeup on over top of that.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Yup.
Hi.
What is your favorite movie other than Deadpool?
Two what is the movie that you're most of?
I am most proud of.
Yes.
Oh,
probably buried.
I mean it was just,
it was really difficult to do and everyone said it was impossible and I love
that experience as we shot the whole thing in Barcelona,
the whole movie takes place in a coffin for those of you who don't know.
And it's just a,
a real Hitchcock kind of a thrill ride now.
So I love that movie.
I still don't know why we shot it in Barcelona and we couldn't just do it in my
living room,
whatever.
I don't make the rules.
So yeah.
Yeah.
Thank you're welcome.
Thank you.
Hello.
So about the last time you played dead pool,
was there like an agreement that if you played that less entertaining version
that you would get to like do a full Deadpool movie?
Actually,
yes.
Peter was how true.
I remember they said,
I've got to,
I got the script and it was during the Hollywood writer's strikes,
there's no writers.
So it just,
it basically said Deadpool shows up,
talks really fast,
annoys everyone around him.
So for the whole first half of that movie,
I play Wade Wilson and I'm just Yada,
Yada,
Yada the whole time.
And I just had to make up all my dialogue because there was no,
no one to write it.
And I had fun.
I love doing that stuff.
So,
um,
but the second half dead pool,
they,
so his fucking mouth shut let,
yeah,
let lasers come out of his eyes and he has like weird knives that fly out of his
hands.
And I,
uh,
I remember saying that's really going to anger some people that's not dead pool.
Um,
and they basically said,
well,
you know,
you can play him or you can,
we can hire,
you know,
someone else to play him.
I don't,
you know,
they pick your guy and he can play.
So for me it was a little bit,
you know,
I was a little bit,
uh,
blackmailed,
I just said,
you know,
all right,
let's do it,
I guess,
and let's see what happens.
And then,
you know,
it's funny as I probably shouldn't be saying this,
but the,
uh,
which is why it's awesome.
Um,
the A,
after the movie had,
was just about to come out,
wolverine was just about to come out and we've got a call from one of the
executives at the studios had,
where are you?
And I said,
I'm,
I'm up in Canada.
He's like,
we need you to fly here right now.
I was like,
what's wrong?
What's going on?
It's like we've tested the movie and people are very upset about the Deadpool,
about everything we did at the dead.
But I was like,
you fucking did it.
I told you.
And they said,
we shot this little tag that happens at the very end after the credits were
Deadpool's severed head is on the ground and I opened my eyes and my mouth is
now open and I go and it was just so dumb.
But we did it anyway,
I guess to sort of make people think that there might be another dead pull up to
that adage.
It then it just rotted and died on the shelves of Fox forever.
They never wanted to make a Deadpool movie after that.
So yeah.
But we made the right one now.
So there you go.
Cool.
Thank you.
Hey there.
Um,
so in the movie you and the taxi driver have a great relationship.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Question is why does he keep driving you around and did he get compensated for
the movie?
Um,
yes,
we paid all our actors.
It was low budget,
but they were,
uh,
they were definitely,
I know the,
in the,
in the movie dope hinder does not,
he is not,
uh,
compensated.
Unfortunately,
Deadpool only pays him in a crisp pie five.
And at one point he gives him a crisp 10 and some life advice,
but no dope hinders that.
That name comes from my,
my friend is in,
in high school and I'm sorry,
elementary school.
I went to school,
this guy named dope hinder and it's actually a,
we're paying tribute to him.
He,
he,
he was killed.
He was struck by lightning,
which is so just utterly crate.
Don't laugh.
No,
I'm cheating.
Uh,
is he,
they're all laughing about it now.
It's fine.
Um,
no.
Uh,
and,
and that's so that's dope.
Hinders dope.
Hinder is a tribute to this guy on that I knew in,
in schools are really cool guy.
Yeah.
There you go.
There's more information than you ever wanted.
And Ryan have been some of the,
your,
uh,
favorite actors or actresses you've worked with in your career?
Uh,
Helen Mirin amazing.
Sandra Bullock is like,
it's classy and fantastic as a human being can get.
Um,
uh,
God,
I'm thinking other actresses that I've worked with that I loved.
Um,
I don't,
you know,
some of you might not necessarily know trailer Howard who I did my TV show with
155 years ago.
She was the girl on the show on two guys,
a girl and a pizza place.
She was an awesome,
awesome person.
Um,
but I've been lucky.
Mary Louise Parker's one that I think is really talented and super,
super smart and cool.
Um,
so yeah,
I know I've had a,
I've been,
I've been pretty lucky in that department of have had a lot of great,
great costars.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Denzel Washington is a wonderful actress.
Well,
you ever heard of him?
Yeah.
Hi,
thank you so much for your time.
I think back on your career and you've done such a variety of different genres
of movies from,
you know,
Sandra Pollock and the proposal too,
animated movies and these adaptations now,
what would you say have been the challenges of doing these different genres and
then also the favorite parts to say,
doing voice animation versus doing something more physical?
Um,
okay.
Well,
my career was largely driven by desperation.
So there's different genre thing is like,
yeah,
you know,
you just,
you find a script that you like and you're,
you know,
you beg someone to let you make it,
uh,
the voiceover acting.
I love voiceover acting.
I love it because there's zero ceiling and you could do and say anything in a
weird way.
Deadpool's there's,
there's a lot of voiceover acting in the movie too,
but,
uh,
um,
so doing animated films have been fun working on crudes and now Croods two has
been incredible and turbo and I just,
I don't know.
I love it.
And it's nice that I can,
you know,
I have something I can show my one year old daughter.
Yeah.
For God's sake.
Everything else is just vile,
so,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's,
yeah.
All right.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
So the marketing for this movie has been insane.
I wanted to know,
did you have a hand in that?
Did you say from the very beginning we should make a Nicholas Sparks billboards
to promote this or did that come in towards the end?
Um,
the Nicholas Sparks,
billboards were not,
I actually was like the last guy on board with that cause I,
they were too good.
I was like,
there are people who are really going to think that this is,
say that like the sequel to the notebook,
you know.
Um,
uh,
so I was a little,
I was a little worried about that one,
but,
uh,
and that was such a hit and I think it was a couple of our marketing guys in
here right now.
Uh,
there's some somewhere they could raise their hands,
but they're chicken shits,
so they won't,
they won't do that.
Um,
they,
they are geniuses and,
and,
but it has been a,
like I said,
it's been an extension of the film,
which is so unusual.
So we've all been,
we've all had our hand in every little piece of it.
Um,
it's been,
uh,
the,
it's been so much of a harder job than the filming actually because it's just
been full time round the clock.
Uh,
you know,
I've never had a social media calendar that I have to adhere to,
which has been just crazy.
You know,
just,
just trying to get stuff out.
Content.
We shot so many videos,
so many viral videos.
Um,
some I write,
some Fox writes some Rhett Rhett and Paul writes.
So,
uh,
it's just been an,
everybody's been all hands on deck,
so,
but it's been so much fun.
I mean everybody just loves it.
You know,
I think a lot of the feedback we've been getting at people sad that the movie's
coming out because the viral videos are going to stop.
But that's just simply not true.
We have,
we have many more.
Yeah,
I think we have time for one more question.
Okay.
Hi Ryan,
this is unrelated to the movie.
I promised to see it,
but I just wanted to ask you about,
um,
being a dad and your new baby.
Can we just talk to us a little about that?
Yeah.
I just found out I had a child,
so it's like a year old.
Walking and talking is no idea who I am.
Uh,
no.
I love it.
It's the best.
Honestly,
it's,
it's been incredible.
I,
thankfully,
I have a wife that we both sort of feel like we don't want to work at the same
time.
So we have the luxury to be able to do that,
you know,
cause oftentimes our jobs or you know,
Thailand or our jobs or in Russia or,
you know,
so we all kind of traveled together and a and stay together and it's been,
it's been amazing.
You know,
my daughter wept though when I would come in with the scar makeup on from
Deadpool.
That was really,
really framed well.
Sometimes it just put it on just for fun.
So she hated that.
But no,
she's,
it's,
it's the best.
Honestly,
it's been like the best thing.
So every cliche is so stupidly true.
You know,
it's like giving birth is like,
you know,
uh,
one of the greatest privileges.
It's so common,
but it's like one of the most profound things that happened.
So many people do it.
But,
um,
so,
but I'm always careful when I talk about it because every like,
I know so many celebrities that talk about when they have a child,
like they're the only fucking human being alive.
That's ever squeezed a kid out of them.
So I'm like,
I'm a little,
I'm always a little bit wary of that.
I have one friend that always like my daughter is quoting checkoff and she's two
and I was like,
your daughter's an asshole.
So yeah,
thank you.
Oh we,
let's not end on that.
[inaudible] you know,
you do interviews and you were in my position.
You like just,
you,
you wake up in the middle of the night at a perfect,
right angle and you're like,
why am I sitting up sweating?
And you're like,
oh,
that fucking question.
I answered that question.
I said that thing.
Yeah.
So I know it's
fine.
All right,
well where,
where do you think the character Deadpool could do the most good in the world?
Where you currently live in?
Oh,
we're where he could do the,
Oh my God.
Well,
certainly the presidential election would be someplace that I would implement
his,
his unique,
unique skill set.
Yeah.
I know he can't.
We did run a,
a brief,
uh,
a Deadpool for El Presidente,
a campaign in the middle of our last week,
I think,
but we pulled it the same day because he's just too immature for that.
So I think he could do some,
do some good there.
I'd love to see him as a pundit because he can't really focus,
so it'll be fun to just see the Tangents,
you know?
I'd love to see bill O'Reilly handle him.
Yeah.
The pundit with a mouth.
Right,
exactly.
It's got to get green.
Good Deadpool,
two of the bundle with them.
All right.
Well,
thank you so much for joining us.
Thank you for guys,
for having me.
[inaudible].